- On this episode, India is not
here and I talk startup life.
(upbeat hip hop music)
- [Gary] You ask questions,
and I answer them.
This is The #AskGaryVee Show.
- Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 197
of the #AskGaryVee show.
Staphon, how are you doing?
- [Staphon] Good. How are you?
- Me too, man. Really good.
Good weekend fantasy baseball
draft was this weekend.
That was a lot of fun.
We drafted here, right here.
I was right there.
Did really well.
Really excited to be
back on a normal show.
This is slightly a
little bit less normal.
First of all, India
is not India today.
Why don't you tell the
Vayner Nation who you are.
- Hi everyone, I'm Sam.
I'm a senior account
executive at VaynerMedia.
- How long have
you been here, Sam?
- I've been here
for about six months.
- How's it going?
- It's going great.
- Like super great?
- Like super great.
- And where you from?
- I'm from New Jersey.
- Where?
- East Brunswick.
- Love it.
Right by Edison.
You like that?
You like Jersey?
- [Staphon] I knew
she was going say that.
- Oh, you knew that.
(all laughing)
Sam works on a very
important account for me.
Some of you might remember if
you've been following my ways
this is right before DailyVee
and Snapchat so you may not know
this but I went up to Buffalo
late last year, in the middle of
the football season, by the
way so is tough territory.
Part of an organization
43North which has an incredible,
incredible program for startups
from all over the world that
submitted thousands of thousands
of submissions last year.
We worked on it last year
Jordy Levy,
a good friend of mine,
is a heavily involved in the
whole rebirth of Buffalo and
that part of New York.
And they're bringing amazing
startups to the area and I got
to judge last year the
competition where
we saw the best of the best.
The last 13 or so startups.
We dwindled it down and we
rewarded a lot of money.
A ton money.
This episode is very
much themed for that.
It is very personal for me.
Want to get the word
out for all of you.
There's so many of you that are
building meaningful startups.
And very honestly the submission
forms and things of that nature
take time so I'm telling you
right now I'm trying to really
help you not waste an hour.
The filter is pretty real.
Actually Sam why don't you get
some more context and some of
the nuts and bolts since
you're obviously working
on it of the competition?
- Sure.
As Gary said it's an amazing
competition for startups.
They're are awarding
$5 million to the top.
The grand prize is a million and
sort of the questions today come
in asking Gary what this could
do for startup and how I could
help you but beyond that you
also get mentorship for some of
the top people.
- The kicker is they have to
move to Buffalo for a year,
right?
- They have to move to Buffalo.
- I don't know what's happening
the winners of ours but the year
before that
company stayed there.
They can stay or leave
eventually but obviously it has
to go there in the
beginning, right?
- Mmhmmm.
- Obviously Buffalo
prefers you set up shop, right?
- Yeah. It's amazing some of the
companies that are down there.
I had no context about Buffalo
before working on this account.
It's an incredible area
for startups in general.
- 100%
- Great incubator space.
- Think a lot of you that know
and a lot of you emailed me and
whether it's Chattanooga,
Tennessee where we have an
office or Columbus, Ohio it
just seems every city is clearly
recognizing the need for digital
driven company talent in their
ecosystem is
incredibly powerful.
It's the new
industrial revolution.
I've been very
passionate about it.
I got to spend a lot of time,
this is tough for me because I
hate the Buffalo Bills and
I know it is what it is.
But it's amazing how
much I love the people
involved in this organization.
It was probably one of the
better two day events that I've
spent time in and I'm excited
that were involved again.
Couple things I don't know.
I don't know
these kind of things.
Are people that are watching
right now if this gets passed
on to startups of a friend's,
couple quick questions,
one, your startup
can be in motion.
- Mmhmmm.
- You can be in a place where
you use this million dollars,
and this is my advice this is
is why I'm asking this,
this is a setup, could use
that million dollars instead
of going getting funding
from somewhere else.
So many of you have companies,
I'm getting tens of thousands of
emails a month of people that
you have companies that are
looking to raise money that
already have some traction,
I highly recommend those
companies enter this competition
'cause you can subsidize
that grand prize for that.
You wont dilute your company as
much plus instead of wasting all
that time pitching after VC
after VC it's in this ecosystem
but you have to have the
scrappiness and the mentality of
willing to go and understand
that you're moving to Buffalo
for that year and
this competition.
Number two, because I know it
kind of rounds up later in the
year, is there a link that
Staphon and I can have now?
Are people are
ready to submit now?
When is the
submission period started?
It started already and
ends May 31st.
- Oh crap so we need to get it--
- It's getting close.
- Okay.
We can have the
link up already to go.
Great? Anything else?
- I think that's it.
- Are you read some questions?
- I am.
- Good, let's do it.
- [Voiceover] Taylor asks,
"How does the startup know
"when to add staff?
"What positions are most
critical to line up first?"
- Taylor, and by the way before
I get into your answer Taylor,
obviously this is a startup
themed episode in honor of the
43North competition.
Taylor, I think that there's a
lot of ways to go about this.
I think you reverse engineer
the founders of the company.
So there's a lot of
things that are needed.
Financial understanding
is needed.
Marketing understanding
Product understanding
is needed.
There's a lot of needs
when you're a small company.
I think what you need to
do is first you hire as soon
as you can afford to.
There are startups that I know
that are literally paying their
founders and CEOs way too much
money because they want to take
the money home.
You've got to start spending it
to invest in your business but
not more than you have.
So if you make 30
or $40,000 a year as an
entrepreneur that's plenty.
You're building an asset
for yourself for the
rest of your life.
It's better than making 100 so
you can take that 70,000 and go
and hire your head of marketing,
hire a project manager,
hire whatever needs you have.
Who to hire is actually
quite easy my opinion.
You hire around the thing that
you most need that you yourself
can't most provide.
I don't hire salespeople
very quickly in my companies.
I don't hire HR
people very quickly.
We didn't have a HR department
or a sales staff for the first
five of the seven years of
VaynerMedia and everyboy thought
that was so crazy because
those of the things that I did.
Those are things that I
could do with my hustle.
But we did have a CFO and a
legal person very quickly over
our means because
those were shortcomings.
I think AJ could have probably
learned it on the job but those
are things we
didn't have as much of.
I think when you hire first is
the thing you need to round out
your team with even if it's not.
Let's say sales is more
important than legal but you're
great at sales I think you still
fix legal even though it's less
in priority because by doubling
down on a person you're still
zero here and you might just
gain 20 to 50 percent here,
where maybe your hustle
and your efforts could just
be the part that gains.
I think that sometimes people
say sales of the number one
thing for this company but even
though I'm great in sales I'm
gonna hire second person and
won't get to that I find that to
be a vulnerability.
I would say up your game by 20
to 40 percent and allow you to
fill some of the other needs
that can become vulnerabilities
on your team.
Cool.
- Second question is
a video submission.
- Let's do it.
- Come from Ace at Painless1099.
- I know this guy.
Ace, just so you guys
know, very nice job,
Ace was one of the finalists,
one of my favorite finalists.
Look how swaggy he looks.
This guy is awesome
you're about to see.
He was probably the
standout personality
for me in the competition.
- Hey Gary. Ace from
Painless1099.
Really quick question, you and
other VCs see a ton of deals
come across your plate.
My question is what are two
or three things that makes one
pitch stand out from
all the other ones?
Thanks Gary.
- You got it.
It's gonna be a good episode.
We haven't done a
lot of startup stuff.
It's been very entrepreneurial.
This will be good.
Ace what stands out ironically
is the way I just set up you and
this question, for me the jockey
the she and he that are pitching
me are normally
80% of the equation.
So many of you have heard that
the classic story of basically I
knew I was going to marry
my wife five minutes in.
If I'm willing to make my
biggest life decision predicated
on my intuition, I'm definitely
going to let it do something so
secondary like investing.
The same way I hire.
I'm a funny hirer.
Everybody used want to
actually watch this Alex, Alex.
This is ironic timing.
This is Alex Klein.
Alex get in here.
You're making an appearance
on the #AskGaryVee show.
- Alright.
- This is literally
crazy timing.
- Okay.
- Because I was about to say
something that is a story
that involves you.
Alex Klein, my brother-in-law,
Lizzie's brother who happens to
do a ton of recruiting from his
own firm for Vayner is this true
or false because we got to go
fast here I don't want you to
like I feel like you
would take up too much time.
- True or false--
- True or false, did you Alex
remember had a recruiting firm
that would make a commission
if we were to place somebody.
Got it that's of
his business works.
True or false you liked it
better when I interviewed people
because I almost hired
everybody versus
everybody else at VaynerMedia?
- True. And false.
- Okay go ahead. Because?
- Well, I think it
works out better.
Long term for everybody, I think
it works out better with this
kind of process
that's in place now--
- Instead of me just
shooting from the hip?
- Yeah.
- Let's get to
actually my point.
Is it true that I'd be more
likely to hire somebody after a
seven minute meeting
and just make a decision.
- 100%
- Okay, cool.
That's it. Thanks, brother.
- Later.
- See you later.
- Bye.
Big Mets loss
opening day, sorry.
- Tough David Wright.
We'll see.
- The funny thing is he
happened to be walking by.
Love the serendipity
of all that.
That's the punchline,
I hire in four seconds.
I make decisions based on my
intuition but a startup has to
have an idea in a
genre that I like.
If you're doing E-sports,
if you're doing VR B-to-B,
if you're doing fully integrated
brand direct consumer consumer
package goods, if you doing
things I believe in and I like
your style, very quickly then
that something I'm going
to be open up to.
If you have those same things
and I don't like your style,
I'm definitely out.
And if you have something that's
not in my wheelhouse that I
believe is going to make money
but I'm in love with your style
I can be intrigued
and sold into you.
The ones I get my deals are
usually genres I like and
I liked the jockey the CEO,
I believe that she and he can
navigate even changing it along
the way because that's what
happens in startups
that's my intuition.
Some people that get my money is
I don't know this much about the
space or passionate about it
but I think you're a superstar.
You have to be better
than the first group.
The things that don't get are
the things I don't like or don't
like that genre and definitely
I don't like the individual.
I don't think they're
going to see it through.
Thanks Ace.
Let's keep it, Alex Klein
making an appearance.
That's a lot of new
characters on today's show.
- From Niall.
- Niall.
- [Voiceover] Niall asks, "Ideas
alone can only get you far, but
"once you gotten off the ground,
what does an investor need to
"see to investment in a startup?
- Well I think investors
all act very differently.
There some black-and-white
binary investors who are looking
for math to add up, right?
Here are your sales, here's your
cost of acquisition your monthly
burn just pure financial
decisions and then other
investors are betting
on the hypergrowth.
You've gone from 0 to 50,000
users in two minutes,
I predict that you're going
to go to 5 million users.
You're not making any money but
you're going to grow faster and
you're going to hit a home run
and I'm okay with the burn and
the financial issues 'cause
you're going to raise more money
as you get bigger and bigger
so you're betting on hard-core
financial principles or
you're betting on the
anticipation of hypergrowth.
I think one thing to keep in
mind is once you're off the
ground people have
something to judge.
So I think a lot of people get
away with getting investors just
on ideas which I think
is a vulnerability to
the whole ecosystem.
But it's funny I've always been
fascinated by companies that are
making money and have a year's
worth of data often times aren't
as sexy as the idea because
investors get romanced in the
upside without any practical
data versus well I already know
you've done for a year and so I
think a lot of youngsters have
been crafty in getting
investment before they have a
product which I think has led to
a much higher return of failures
which I think people need to
become more practical and so I
think, just for everybody and
for you, once you have some data
be prepared to be grilled a
little bit more because people
have something to judge.
I think that's great and
healthy and needs
to be more the standard.
- [Sam] Cool.
Next video submission.
- 'Kay.
- [Sam] It is from Caitlin
and Christine from Plum.
- Yes I remember these
gals. They were awesome.
HR love it.
- Hi Gary.
For an early stage startup that
just received 500,000, 600,000
or $1 million in capital, what
are the critical things they
should be looking to address?
- These guys have
a great company.
Let's make sure we link up
both Ace's and their company and
Plum's company in
my description.
Staphon make sure you
team up with Sam on that.
Well look I mean first and
foremost, you don't blow it.
The amount of people that
have blown through their five or
600, million in cash because
they didn't have a strategy of
what they were going to do
with money is unbelievable.
It's unbelievable how much cash
and wallet is just burning for
so many startup
founders it's quite said.
So I think you have to have a
real plan for it and again no
different than the first
question on this episode,
you have to have a strategy on
where you're going to deploy it.
What are your biggest needs?
To me I like to invest in
things that bring back
dollars in the midterm.
I don't need the short term but
I don't need the longest term.
I think sometimes
people are too...
It's funny, ideas are shit until
execution I like to say a lot
because I think most
founders get caught on
one side or the other.
Some founders take $500,000
and they want that 500,000
to make them 800,000.
It's all transactional.
Sales, conversion.
Other founders start thinking
about what their company
needs in three years.
In three years, we're going to
need video editing software so
let's buy that now and you
didn't get to three years.
By the time that you spent all
the money that was what created
this scenario you never getting
to those three years from now.
I think much like marketing in
the year that you live in,
day trading attention, some
of my marketing principles,
I deploy in my
operating principles.
What is the most important
thing with that money right this
second that isn't short-term
sales turn 500 into 600,000 but
what is not the were going to
need this in three years so
let's spend it?
By the way furniture and rent
and all these things that's
where people waste money.
AJ and I started
this company in
a conference room
of another company.
This is not a
super fancy office.
Right? Yeah.
It's good.
I'm happy about that.
This is actually pretty fancy
compared to where we were a year
ago so like people just waste
money on a lot of things
that don't matter.
Now, it can't be so screwed
up here that people
don't want to come here.
But we don't need $8000
recliner chairs for everybody
and that's what a lot
of startups do. It's crazy.
They spend more time and energy
on like how fancy this coffee
machine is gonna be than
actually building
a god damn business.
So what you do with it?
You better know what to
do with it or your startup
is in deep shit.
Don't ask GaryVee, I hate
third person, don't ask me.
Figure out what to do with it.
Make it practical as hell
because that money will
disappear fast and the only
thing that will disappear faster
is your hopes and dreams about
your business if you don't know
what to do with it.
You like that?
- [Sam] I loved it.
- [Gary] It's real right?
- Yeah.
- Jersey.
- [Sam] Jersey.
- [Voiceover] Efferent Labs
asks, "When assessing the
"scalability for a company,
"what are the things
you look for?"
- You know Zach, I'm not looking
for much I'm usually doing that
homework and living that
business life beforehand.
It's not hard for me, I
don't ever struggle with
understanding...I don't of you
noticed in my face there Staphon
I was like thinking about it
I see what's happening.
I have such a good understanding
of end consumer dynamics,
the marketplace, the market,
the stuff I talk about for
the last 10 years of my life.
A lot of venture
capitalists don't.
A lot of business people don't
but what I'm really good at is
understanding demand.
I understand the customer.
I rarely ever struggle with
being like who's going
to buy your thing.
I can make those connections
in my head pretty easily.
And so I'm not spending a
lot, anything is scalable.
Anything is scalable in theory
because you can either humanly
scale it or you can
scale it with technology.
You just have to
understand if people want it.
Do people want
mattresses sent to their home?
That's what people
messed up with Casper
and those kinds of companies.
Uber.
We thought it was going
to be a 1% problem
when we first heard it.
Those early conversation were
like well okay there's enough
rich people. Maybe we
underestimated the fact that
everybody wants to buy time
and we didn't understand that.
Eight dollar green juice.
That maybe didn't seem right to
a lot of people because who's
going to pay that?
People are paying luxury fees
now for their body and their
health and so this generation
the kids and not just the kids
I like to make that joke,
millennial's and Gen X and
everybody, everybody now is more
willing to spend money on their
health and wellness versus
an 80 inch screen television.
The 1980s and 90s mentality of
an 80 inch screen television and
the most extensive car you could
get has been replaced with
60 inch television, solidly
awesome car but an extra $20,000
to buy eight dollar
green juices and
a one-year subscription
to Soul Cycle.
If you didn't understand that
was happening, you missed it.
Do I think people will pay
$50 to go to the movies?
The answer is yes.
Has there been an execution that
I've seen that makes me feel
like that's the right bet?
I haven't yet.
I know Cuban's got some stuff in
his world but will people pay
$50 to go to the
movies absolutely.
Has anybody really executed the
added values that force people
at all income levels to do it?
Not yet.
But if I saw
somebody pitch me,
I'd be like yes that
could happen.
I have a good understanding
for consumer to understand where
things are going.
How do I navigate?
Do I think there is a demand
currently or could be bubbled up
quickly to justify the value and
the lifecycle of that business
or is it too early?
VR consumer.
Do I think enough people have
VR units at home to watch seven
hours worth of content?
I don't and so I'm not investing
the companies that are selling
based on that reality because
I don't think that's going to
happen next 24 months.
So the punchline is do I believe
consumers are going to do it in
a short enough time so that the
business can actually make money
in that lifecycle?
- [Sam] Cool.
- Cool.
- [Sam] Last video submission.
- Last.
- Comes from
Energy Intelligence.
- Yes, let's do it.
- Hey Gary. What's going on?
There are a lot of reasons why
startups are flocking to
Silicon Valley and New York but
it seems like emerging startup
markets are becoming
increasingly viable.
What are cities like
Buffalo doing right?
- I think it's becoming
viable because people are
all buying into the dream.
What they're doing right is
there's more money available to
invest in startups.
Startups are simple animals.
They want expertise,
mentorship and money.
Silicon Valley is going to win
because a lot of developers in
San Francisco and things of that
nature and if you going for big,
big tech ideas you
need that talent.
Things are Buffalo and New
Jersey and even New York don't
fully have the kind of
engineering talent that a
San Francisco has so if you got
an eBay or Facebook or
a Microsoft ambition well then
you've got to really debate
being out there to
have the engineering talent.
In the beginning these
things can start anywhere.
Facebook started in Boston.
Pinterest started
in Pennsylvania.
You can start them anywhere and
more importantly if you're doing
things that are not grossly
reliant on engineering talent
you can do them anywhere.
And the things that Buffalo
and Cleveland and Detroit and
Columbus, Ohio and Chattanooga,
Tennessee are doing is that the
rich people in those areas
are starting to write checks to
startups and so then
it becomes agnostic.
And more importantly there's
such a rejuvenation of city life
across the whole country so all
these really it's amazing to see
the cities of America go
from places that were seedy,
ironically, to having high
ceiling lofts that are a great
price and great coffee
shops and cool wine bars.
We're living through a very
interesting time in the city
rejuvenation of the United
States and with that comes the
natural artist and tech talent
and so I think what they're
doing right is the riding the
wave to be very frank with you
and I also think that there
are wealthy 50, 60, 70 and
80-year-olds in those
towns that love their town.
Right? That want
to see it succeed.
I've even had feelings towards
Jersey on this issue and I'm
still fairly young. When I 70,
80 I'll definitely want to make
Edison, New Jersey an
ecosystem of something.
I think those
practical behaviors is why.
It's just the evolution
of the marketplace.
Cool.
- [Sam] That's it.
- Thanks for doing your part.
- [Sam] Yeah.
- Enjoyed it?
- I loved it.
- Good. No worries.
Question of the day:
Tell me your startup story?
This is an opportunity for me to
look at the comment section of
both Facebook and YouTube, do
so much good for you some of you
who follow me on Instagram see
when I say tell this community
about yourself and that's your
favorite post because you get to
talk about yourself.
In the comment section today
tell me your startup story.
A.K.A. Tell the world about your
startup or B tell me a story
about your sister's start up or
how you were part of a startup
in the 90s that failed
and this is what happened.
Or your favorite startup.
Tell me your startup story.
And for all of you that are
serious make sure you click the
links below and sign up
for the 43North competition.
I don't think I get
to be judge.
I don't think they
do back to back judges.
Hopefully it works out the
Jets-Bills schedule or
I might just fly for the day.
If any of you make it to the
finals I'll shoot up there
and say hey. Cool.
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
(upbeat synth music)